à 56 ans et indo américaine et la
première femme noire à être élue
vice-présidente un symbole du rêve
américain car depuis 30 ans elle défie
tous les pronostics
un espoir pour la communauté
afro-américaine et en particulier les
femmes ouais mais bon ce soir
les femmes qui se sont battues vie
autant sacrifier pour l'égalité la
liberté et la justice pour tous y
compris les feuilles noires qui sont
souvent trop souvent oubliée mais qui
trouve si souvent qu'elles sont l'épiné
dorsale de notre démocratie
de mère indienne et de père jamaïcain
elle a grandi à berkeley dans un
quartier modeste avec sa soeur et sa
mère à qui elle a tenu à rendre hommage
quand elle est arrivée d'inde à l'âge de
19 ans elle n'a peut-être pas vraiment
imaginé ce moment mais elle croyait si
profondément en une amérique où un tel
moment est possible et donc je perds
sahel et aux générations de femmes
noires
waziers tic blanche latine amérindienne
qui tout au long de l'histoire d'une
autre nation hôte ouvert la voie à ce
moment là ce soir
elle devient ensuite juriste puis
procureur une dizaine d'années à san
francisco en 2012 c'est la première
femme procureur noir de californie connu
pour ses réquisitoires tranchant et ses
prises de position musclées et même
qualifiées de dures parfois par son côté
très répressive envers les petits
légumes en 2017 c'est la première femme
originaire d'asie du sud à entrer au
sénat une force de travail durant son
parcours kamala harris n'a eu de cesse
d'évoluer en politique et sa ténacité a
toujours été une marque de fabrique
c'est maintenant que commence le vrai
travail le travail essentiel pour sauver
des vies il vaincre cette épidémie pour
reconstruire une autre économie afin
qu'elle fonctionne pour les travailleurs
pour éradiquer le racisme systémique
dans notre système judiciaire et notre
société pour lutter contre la crise
climatique pour venir notre pays est
bien l'homme et notre nation
une élection dans un contexte de crise
blacklight madder suite à la mort de
georges floyd et un climat de tensions
raciales entretenu par l'ex président
selon certains commentateurs l'arrivée
de kamala harris peut être un véritable
atout pour joe biden qui s'est fortement
appuyé sur l'électorat afro-américain
durant sa campagne
bernotat démocrates républicains
indépendants progressiste modéré
conservateur jeunes vieux citadins
banlieusards bureau gay hétéro
transsexuels blancs latinos asiatiques à
meyrin
1 je suis sincère surtout dans les
moments où cette campagne était au plus
bas
la communauté afro-américaine la
communauté afro américaine s'est à
nouveau levé pour moi vous avez toujours
assurer mes arrières et je vais assurer
les vôtres une femme qui aurait pu être
à la place de joe biden mais fortement
critiquée pendant les primaires pour ses
positions sur les politiques de
ségrégation raciale dans les années 70
elle a finalement laissé sa place mais
sa trajectoire fulgurante la met d'ores
et déjà en position pour une possible
campagne en 2024